we have a very special treat for you
this morning amanda gorman the youngest
inaugural poet in u.s history is giving
us an exclusive preview of poetry from
her new book just happen to have it
right here call us what we carry the
poem she selected is called fugue it's
an emotional look at the impact of the
pandemic here you go
[Music]
don't get us wrong we do pound for what
has passed but more so all that we
passed by unthinking unknowing when what
we had was ours
[Music]
there was another gap that choked us the
simple gift of farewell goodbye by which
we say to another thanks for offering
your life into mine by goodbye we truly
mean let us be able to say hello
again
[Music]
this is edgeless doubt every cough
seemed catastrophe every approximate
person a potential peril we mapped each
sneeze and sniffled certain the virus we
had run away from was now running
through
us
we slept the days down we wept the year
away frayed and afraid we spent days as
the walking dead dreading disease in
disaster we awaited horrors building up
leviathans before they arose we could
not pull our heads from the raucous deep
every time we fell heart first into the
news head first dreadfirst our bodies
tight intense with
what now
yet who has the courage to inquire
what
if what hope shall we shelter within us
like a secret second smile private and
pure
[Music]
and so we forage for anything that feels
like this the click in our lung that
ties us to strangers how one among those
we care for most we shift with instincts
like the flash of a school a fish our
regard for one another not tumored just
transformed by hello we mean let us not
say goodbye again there is someone we
would die for
feel that fierce unshifting truth that
braced and ready sacrifice that's what
love does and makes a fact faced beyond
fear we have lost too much to lose we
lean against each other the way water
bleeds into itself this glass hour
paused bursts like a loaded star
belonging always to us
what more
must we
believe in
bravo amanda bravo she read that guys
without a prompter well it's her words
but still and special shout out to chris
bender the producer who put that
together amazing the way amanda walked
around the building and read her words
beautifully
beautifully
we have lost too much to lose we'll be
right back